the key component in all this is once
you stumble
across those red flags you start the
documentation process
i encourage the pi route because it was
very successful for me
because um these law firms only work
with pis that can sit and testify
in a courtroom and and really when it
comes to
the the marital court process that it's
the story that matters
and whatever side tells the best story
is the one that wins i mean sometimes it
doesn't even depend on the evidence
but pis are coached they're structured
they know how to deliver
on the stand and that's what really hit
the ball out of the park
for my case in particular was the pi was
so good and on top of that
he had a reputation with the court
systems he had been working
you know rumor had it he saved a former
judge's life
so the judge all judges all knew this
guy and and these are the type of social
dynamics you want to talk about with
your lawyer
is you you want to make sure that you're
going to get somebody that the court is
familiar with because
you know courts have small localized you
know microcosm communities right
and they all you know the recruit you
know court staff recorders lawyers you
know you know bailiffs they all know
each other
so if you if you get if you get a court
situation where you have somebody that's
got a good standing reputation on the pi
side it's it's a home run every time
and that's what that's one of the
questions you want to address with the
lawyers
hey how long has this person been doing
this work you know make sure you you get
somebody that's been doing the guy that
i got had
was a retired cop and he'd been doing
the pi work for 20 years and he had
already been a cop for 30.
so i mean taking your entire like family
net worth and access to your kids and
and everything that that unfolds with
untying the knot you don't want to deal
with an amateur i
i totally co-sign what you're saying
there yeah and just
just do the right thing ask the
questions um and and you know don't
don't just go with one lawyer
shop around a couple other lawyers like
i said there's there's law firms that
say hey we can get you to the finish
line but you got to do all this work
i just didn't have that that bandwidth
at that time but um
but but back back to what
back to the evolution of the case is
once we got the albright factors
established um
you know i you know i went ahead took
pictures of you know
her her laundry routine you know how she
cares for herself you know
i mean the court looks at everything i
mean if your wife can't
keep up keep a clean house and you're
the one that's picking up the slack all
the time
i mean that's a factor they look about
with her ability to care for the kids
well if she can't do her own laundry and
she can't clean up her bathroom and she
can't cook her own food and she can't
how she how can she do it with kids so
you know cleaning up or did you have a
house cleaner come by
well we we had a house cleaner
previously but once i had
when i had come home um i took a little
bit of a pay cut to come home
so those those niceties were kind of or
kind of thrown off the window actually
got rid of a couple cars to downsize to
some cheaper vehicles as well so um
and but you know the the mantra of the
relationship had always been
oh that's what we want that's what we
both want and then once once we got to
that point
i you know i could almost see it in her
eyes the oh [ __ ]
moment like this is for real he's really
coming home and he's really going to be
here all the time
and you just can't keep up you know as
my lawyer put it
as no human being when they're living a
second life
can keep up that act in in the long term
eventually
the facade starts to break they slip up
and you know of course and that's what
happened in my ex-wife's case and she
started to slip up and i took that
opportunity to
document but you know it's critical that
you keep status quo
you know play the beta role yes honey
you know do everyth
you know my laura told me we want her
we want her out we want her getting into
trouble
so you be extra nice you encourage you
know encourage the honeydews
you know honey i'll take care all the
dishes i'll do the laundry i'll i'll do
take care of the kids
you go out and have a good time yeah you
know what you can give them enough rope
and they'll always hang themselves right
and that's exactly the case because you
know she she saw
saw this change in me and looked at it
and said wow
you know i can really he's really giving
me some freedom here
and in reality you know had the pi on
her and the freedom was
exactly the rope that she hung herself
on you know i started encouraging
multiple nights out you know hey you
know oh you want to go out on friday
night you know what shoot go out on
saturday night too it's all right i got
this i'm home with the kids it's all
right no big deal
so and and for six months that's the way
the game was played
but the reward in the end was worth
every
every bit of it the pi was worth every
penny the the strategy was worth
everything
you